We are all looking forward to the future, but have you ever considered that you can only see the past?
It takes just 80 milliseconds for your brain to process information,
that means you never really live in the present.
Not to mention, your eyes need time to perceive light from an object,
so you actually see what they looked like a fraction of a second ago.
For example, when you look at the stars,
you see light that has taken years to travel, and so you see what the stars looked like.
The next time you look, you must realize that that light has traveled through everything
the universe, until it comes to you.
So watch out, or not, because seconds ago you were miles away.
How? The earth revolves around its axis while it revolves around the sun.
But the sun also revolves in the galaxy, which in turn flies into the universe.
That you then have the chance to see that light, quite incredible.
It puts the things of dimensions in a perspective.
Such as the fact that a dust particle is almost between the Earth and a subatomic particle.
In the meantime, there are more atoms in a glass of water than glass in all oceans.
And talking about oceans, if all the oxygen on earth disappeared for 5 seconds,
then the hydrogen atoms are released and evaporate into space.
Either way, you cannot see the Great Wall from space.
You can see the air pollution.
Do you feel disoriented?
If you travel north, you'll end up south.
But if you travel west, you keep traveling west.
The chance that you will have an accident along the way to purchase a lottery ticket is greater than winning the main prize.
Meanwhile, when a pregnant woman has a damaged organ,
like a heart attack
sends the fetus stem cells to the damaged organs,
to help it recover.
Warm outside?
The temperature of the testicles at rest is approximately 35 degrees Celsius,
or 95 degrees Farhenheit,
on a warm day that means literally "Hot as Balls".
Hopefully that made you smile,
Because even made laughter can give the brain the idea that you are really smiling,
which in turn can produce endorphins and joy.
People are just machines that convert energy into ideas.
And it appears that all history and time has given you the opportunity to hear this, so thanks for your time.
If you want to know more facts, make sure you follow us on Facebook and Twitter, where we post new science facts every day.
And if you want to see the details on the next episode and behind the scenes,
check out our Instagram page and Twitter, and subscribe to science every week!